الزياره الامريكيه الرفيعه المستوى هي
الاولى منذ الوعد التي قطعه الرئيسان
الصيني شيجن والامريكي جو بايد ان الشهر
الماضي في بالي والمتمثل ببث الدفء في
العلاقات بين بلديهما في الصين سيتعين على
الوفد اكمال ما بداه بايضا بعد اجتماعه
الاخير مع الشيعه لها مش قمه مجموعه
العشرين في بالي منتصف نوفمبر لكن ما هي
ابرز الخلافات بين البلدين فلنبدا
مشاهدينا من بؤره الصراع اي بحر الصين
الجنوبي كما نشاهد هنا حيث يحتوي باطن هذا
البحر على احتياطه قد يبلغ 10 مليارات
برميل من النفط وعلى ثروه هائله من الغاز
الطبيعي لم تستثمر بعد ويشكل ممر لما
قيمته خمسه ريونات دولار من التجاره
البحريه العالميه السنويه ولهذا تتمسك
الصين بالسيطره على هذا البحر وهو واقع
طبعا يزعج الولايات المتحده
ما تحطي شهريه بين البلدين التي بدات منذ
مده طويله هي لب الصراع بين الجانبين الا
انها تصاعدت بعهد ترامب الذي اججها
بانتهاج سياسات صارمه ضد بكين
بكين بدورها تضغط على اداره لالغاء
التعريفات الجمركيه التي فرضت في عهد
ترامب على منتجاتها وسيلاها خلاف اخر
يواجهه البلدين وهو صناعه الرقائق
الالكترونيه واشباه الموصلات اضافه لحروب
الابتكار وذكاء الاصطناعي التي تشهد فيها
الصين تقدما كبيرا يقلقوا على الشيطان اما
تايوان فتعتبر وتعتبر ايضا من اهم القضايا
الخلافيه بين البلدين حيث تعتبر الصين
طبعا تايوان جزءا من اراضيها التي
ستستعيدها ذات يوم بالقوه اذا لزم الامر
الامر الذي تعارضه واشنطن بشده
[موسيقى]